I was such an awkward nerdy weird little
kid and I sort of knew it and I sort of
hated that about myself I hate I've
always known that I was smart and I
always had like okay
I'm not cool I'm not good looking I'm
not good at sports
but I'm smart so I was like that's gonna
be the thing that's gonna like get me if
I ever get anywhere it's gonna be that
so yeah it was really like living a lot
in the mind imagining thinking
that was sort of all I thought I could
really do
um and I was also like I really poured
myself into my studies I studied a lot
me too I thought did you really ask oh I
was a terrible grind I mean yeah early
on I was just uh I have nothing left to
offer but what I can do is I'm going to
um I'm going to use my brain and I'm
going to excel in this area because uh
and because I loved comedy as a kid yeah
and I loved making my friends laugh but
I made a conscious decision I'm from
Boston Massachusetts I've got a weird
name and odd hair that's never happening
I need to put that aside buckle down and
get into a really good college and so in
a very unglamorous nerdy way I was I
worked really hard on my studies
got into a good really good school and
then immediately bumped into the human
magazine yeah shot me right into this
world which is very hilarious that my
attempt to escape comedy uh and and turn
my back on it because it would never
happen led me to this place the Lampoon
it completely turned everything around
and it gave you I think as a kid I think
that's studying what it gave me it seems
like it gave you was like a really
strong work ethic yeah you know I
studied all day all the time and I also
I sort of do look back I wasn't really
funny until College I come from a very
funny family my whole family is very
funny extended family everybody's always
making jokes it's clearly like a value
for us like it's important to all of us
to be funny
um it's not effortless everybody's like
trying to get a laugh all the time but I
felt like I couldn't really hang with
that until College because I didn't
really feel like a person until College
because I felt like I had had kind of
nothing to offer so I didn't know who I
was yep
um and uh and then in college suddenly
people were like hey you're funny I'm
like oh I now have an adjective I can
use to describe myself I felt like that
was the first time I really felt like I
had anything
was was being funny and then it sort of
became the entire [ __ ] world for a
very very long time all I cared about
was comedy and now I'm I'm sort of you
know I still obviously care a lot about
comedy but trying to do other stuff has
been uh also very exciting and
satisfying how old were you when you I
was 18 18. I came on my own I went to
college it's interesting you know that's
that's much later than I thought what
did you know about
the America when you came what were you
thinking what were your preconceptions
I'd seen a lot I've seen a lot of movies
so you know there's Gremlins everywhere
right
sometimes one day we'll just repeat
itself you thought Harrison Ford was
President yeah
I think I hope I don't if I do I
hope what what
yeah
uh we don't get in a DeLorean until
unless you want your mom to hit on you
so I grew up I understood all that about
American culture did you see our
commercials or no you didn't see the
commercials I didn't really see very
much commercials I had an aunt in
Singapore who would record like cartoons
off the TV so I saw like foreign
commercials like Singapore commercials
which were a lot more like American
commercials than Pakistani commercials
but I didn't and I remember I first
visited America when I was like 13 or 14
and it was an ad for KFC and they were
like ripping on McDonald's by name like
they had like a clown who kind of looked
like Ronald McDonald but like [ __ ] up
looking yeah
and uh I was like how can they do that
they could just make fun of another
company I mean I'm still wondering right
now how they could do that you can't go
after Ronald you can go after McDonald's
but you can't you can't go after Ronald
McDonald oh you're so angry he's like a
religious figure you know yeah yeah
Santa Claus yeah
Ronald McDonald Ronald McDonald that's
the way McDonald's burned the colonel in
effigy yeah retaliation became a huge
War yeah it got it was like East Coast
West Coast it got really a lot of people
died yeah there's a lot of yeah yeah
Hamburglar became ham murderer
[Laughter]
yeah it was uh so so I knew that about
American culture but I was gonna say you
know I was so I knew I loved movies and
TV so much I didn't really leave the
house very much other kids played
outside I really watched movies and TV
shows for like most of my life and I
played video games so I feel very very
grateful that I get to work in this
industry that I've loved my entire life
my dad left movies and that's who but
you know someone like Emily she
understood that she was weird and
different from everyone else and she
really leaned into it so she was like a
goth in high school in the seventh grade
she started dyeing her hair with with
Sharpie herself and kids would make fun
of her she would like draw all over her
clothes so it's interesting to see that
you know both of us kind of felt like we
didn't fit and I tried to become
invisible and she was like [ __ ] you I'm
gonna be the weirdest person in the
world that's so fascinating I you said
something that I completely connect to
which is you didn't
uh you didn't know who you were you know
when you're younger and I remember very
clearly having just thinking I because I
I would look at my brothers and sisters
and think that they all had you know
they were all defined people and I
remembered feeling
um like a Mr Potato Head that they
hadn't put any pieces on yet went they
had to put the nose or the eyes on or
the mouse oh my God that's heartbreaking
yeah and I remember thinking um just a
potato then yeah just a I was a plastic
potato which is the worst kind no
nutrients well you are Irish yeah
exactly and so and so and mostly plastic
yeah and uh there's nothing inside
and uh no one plays with me anymore just
a hollow plastic
no one's wanted me
no no come on come on we're just having
fun but um I remembered thinking trying
out you know I know I'll be Civic minded
guy you know how you know
what's talking about causes was that
what it was yeah you know I'll be this
guy I'll be that guy I mean I would
permits I would try things and I didn't
think I didn't know what my natural
enthusiasms were and I didn't think
comedy counted you know and so yeah I
would try things on at times and and and
you know and I remember telling my
mother
you know one day well I'm gonna go to
law school this is when I was like in
you know 12 years old or something and
she went really because she was really
proud and I went yes yes I'm going to be
a great lawyer and then later on saying
I'll be an author you know I would just
declare these things that didn't have
anything behind them yeah and I'm I do
try to impart this to uh to young people
very young people I try to tell them it
took me so long to figure things out you
have no idea sometimes how long it takes
and they live in this culture where
they're constantly being shown images or
or hearing interviews with people uh say
in their 30s I think the gap between 15
and 30 is far more than 15 years I think
it's just this massive massive Gap
because those are the years where you
figure out who you are
and sometimes people really are still
worth figuring it out some people don't
and you just I think you have to figure
out that you're always going to be
figuring stuff out you're always growing
changing and I think finding some sort
of way to feel comfortable inside
yourself and then knowing that who you
are is going to change and the things
you want is gonna Are Gonna Change
um I think that's key you know I I had
this thing in in high school where so I
left Pakistan and I and I came here
and I sort of lost touch with all my
friends from high school
and then I kind of got back in touch
with them in the pandemic
and we we sort of started talking again
and I was like first of all I was like
oh I stole all of your senses of humor
that's what I did yeah they all talk
exactly the way they talked then and I
was like all right I took all of that
this is something I say on your show
that I learned from you know my friend
Tariq
um and then one of them messaged me on
the side and was like why did you stop
talking to us like we love you and at
some point you just stopped responding
to us and I realized that I thought in
high school that I was this like charity
case because I felt I had nothing to
offer and I thought they were just being
nice to me that's why they wanted to
hang out with me and I told him that and
he's like that's crazy we all really
liked you yeah and I just at that age
could not imagine anybody liking me
because I I didn't think that there was
anything to like
um and so you know I don't know what the
what the point to that is but it's it's
being comfortable with myself and liking
who I am it took a long time